tout
[Musique]
on voit ici une scène de dissection dans
un amphithéâtre
ce traité c'est la date de naissance de
l'anatomie moderne alors la baleine a
déjà son harpon le dauphin il est moche
leur dauphin on a là quelque chose qui
correspond bien au goût de la
renaissance qui fait l'inventaire du
monde connu
[Musique]
ce qui va changer en fait entre le mode
de production du livre entre moyen âge
et la renaissance c'est qu'au moyen-âge
on est vraiment une logique de la
demande de la commande avec l'imprimerie
on passe à une logique de l'offre
un livre ces composés par une suite de
caractères en plomb qui sont
indépendants les uns des autres et qu'on
va aligner à l'aide d'un outil qu'on
appelle un composteur qui se présente
comme ça jusqu'à composer des mots des
lignes et ensuite des pages au milieu du
xvième siècle une presse avec deux
ouvriers précié peut imprimer 2516 recto
verso par jour
alors le livre circulant en très grande
partie à l'époque en feuilles et ce sera
le client qui ayant acheté la pile de
feuilles va ensuite allé chez un
religieux et choisir en fonction de ses
moyens de faire soit une reliure en peau
de truies soit une reliure en vo orné
d'un décor doré comme celle-là on
n'utilise pas d'acide comme on le fait à
partir du 19ème siècle pour fabriquer le
papier est la conséquence de ça c'est
que alors que nos livres des 19e et 20e
siècles s'autodétruisent très rapidement
les papiers de la renaissance sont des
papiers qui souvent sont d'une blancheur
et d'une qualité rare etienne très très
bien sur la longueur certains osent
ouvrage à destination du public
universitaire était imprimé
volontairement avec des marges assez
confortable pour permettre aux étudiants
de prendre des notes et un endroit où le
gamin car elles notées çà a dessiné une
tête dans un hommage skull c'est pour ce
genre de détail que je fais de
l'histoire du livre je pense
[Musique]